[Music]  we have a serious problem huh no time  anymore either so many problems  no no say no you're gonna offer me money  I'll still say no you're gonna appeal to  my better nature and I'm gonna say no  because at that output there's no I  saved why don't we sit down on enjoy a  couple of beers  I thought we'd give you on your way  Jonas this happened this morning  the may have encountered the same  species you did down here  a shark  Megalodon excuse me I said a Megalodon a  living fossil thought to have been  extinct over two million years love  people are gonna die if we don't find  him killing him she's coming  of course you'd think of she it's a  great day to go fishing  he's getting right  [Music]  saying we opened up a superhighway for  giant sharks  now just a big  I want to make this thing bleed  [Music]  [Music]  you  you